This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Harry’s.
Body shaving is a tradition in some sports…
Maybe I should try
it out… you know… for sports.
Shaving in sports is a big deal, cyclists
do it to reduce road rash, and cut drag; swimmers
do it to feel slicker in the water, and cut
drag, and body builders do it… well… to
look like this[a][b].
Wowza.
Whew…
Anyway, you can see that speedy sports shave
their bodies to CUT DRAG.
They're saying, cleaning off these follicles
are going to help you win a race!
How do you feel about leg shaving for swimmers?
Meh?!
Yeah…
That's how I felt about it.
Kind of just like, okay, go ahead!
As long as you feel better!
But science says I might have been playing
down a SIGNIFICANT advantage without knowing
it!
Drag reduction in speed sports is a huge deal.
Cyclists have been doing it for over 100 years.
But it wasn't until 1987 that a study was
conducted for Bicycling Magazine by an engineer
in a wind tunnel.
This study determined the speed savings were
0.6 percent.
Which is just sad.
That's SO small.
Maybe enough to save five seconds over an
hour at 23 mph (37kph).
The results were so piddling, and wind tunnels
so expensive to use, no one ever repeated
the experiment… until now.
A special bicycle-specific wind tunnel was
built by the Specialized cycling company,
and the researchers had free use of it for
testing!
Coincidentally, one of their riders had shaved
that day, so they figured, why not?
Don't cost nothing, and they found the shaving
had reduced the cyclists drag 7 percent!!
SEVEN.
This meant, a cyclist in a 25 mile (40km),
one hour race could save 79-seconds by simply
shaving their bod!
These findings were revolutionary, so to double-check
they tested five more cyclists.
They all saved 50-82 seconds over 40 km.
WHAT?!
They also tested different helmets, different
positions and long-sleeved racing gear finding
significant power savings here and there.
They were shocked.
Shaving works, at least in cycling.
In swimming, the jury is still in over its
head.
Common wisdom is shaving is mostly psychological.
HowStuffWorks says, "Razors strip dead skin
cells off the body in addition to hair, exposing
a fresh layer of sensitive skin cells."
Because of that, the swimmer FEELS better
in the water.
Though a 1989 study, the only one I could
find, tested the physiology of shaved and
unshaved swimmers while also testing their
drag reduction.
Turns out, physiologically, there were no
differences in heart rate, oxygen use, or
lactic acid buildup (which is what makes your
muscles burn during exercise).
There WERE, however, noticeable drag reductions.
Mentally, swimmers probably believe themselves
to be slicker and more powerful in the water,
even without science, but we're here to back
them up.
Ladies and dudes, you're totally slicker.
Some runners will also get into the habit
of body shaving, expecting that over a long
race they might reduce drag, but more often
the clothing worn will produce more drag than
the lack of hair could ever make up for.
So instead, most Olympic runners today wear
computer-designed, NASA influenced running
suits, designed to help them glide through
the air.
Or so they say!